[Music]
on TV on r Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on pan un censored from New
York City Fury in Israel as the UN Chief
appears to qualify the Hamas Terror
attacks and prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu warns the ground invasion is
coming imminently is it any way out of
this deadly and desperate crisis I'll
ask Israeli intellect juval Noah Harari
and the Palestinian infal leader Mustafa
bouti plus I'm joined live by by the
podcaster who caught the world's
attention when she said this when a
thousand plus Palestinian babies die you
don't feel the same you don't feel the
same as when I tell you one of your own
has died but these are our
[Music]
own live from New York this is peer
Morgan
uncensored good evening from New York
City and welcome to PE Morgan un sensor
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu was crystal clear tonight a
ground invasion is coming and coming
soon he said thousands of terrorists
have been killed already and that's only
the beginning the months ahead will
clearly be Grim the war in Israel is
already inciting visceral emotions
across the world and they're in danger
of boiling over from vile anti-Semitism
on our streets leaving many Jewish
people feeling unwanted and unsafe to
grief and fury over the catastrophe now
escalating in Gaza this genuine anger on
both sides and it's very understandable
for Israelis this was about the brutal
Massacre on October the 7th and
defending their country from people who
simply don't believe they have a right
to exist for the Palestinians and their
supporters and many Muslims around the
world this is about the agony and
anguish that began 56 years before the
Hamas attacks with Israeli occupation
that's the point that Antonio guer is
the UN Secretary General tried to make
when he said this it is important to
also recognize the attacks by did not
happen in a
vacuum the Palestinian people have been
subjected to 56 years of suffocating
occupation the problem with that framing
is that there's no way of really
qualifying what happened on October the
7th there's no historic intellectual or
spiritual justification for deliberately
murdering babies in their cribs burning
families alive kidnapping Holocaust
Survivors this was the Furious response
of Israel's ambassador to the
UN Hamas is the Minister explained
beheaded babies burned
families raped women
abducted kids babies Holocaust
Survivors and the SG is blaming the
victim you are blaming
Israel this is a pure blood liel this is
a pure blood liel and I think that the
Secretary General must
resign yes Palestinians and their
supporters are justifiably Furious about
the way they've been treated
historically they have legitimate
heartfelt grievances that go back
decades but October the 7th was
unequivocally evil it did happen in a
vacuum we've seen nothing like this
because there's no way that ordinary
Palestinians I don't believe supported
what they did that day I can understand
why Palestinians are angry are angry
they can be disgusted as we are by Hamas
while still feeling AG grieved at their
own suffering doesn't get the same level
of attention Egyptian podcaster Rak
maain caught the world's attention for
this passionate explanation to
CNN when a thousand plus Palestinian
babies die you don't feel the same you
don't feel the same as when I tell you
one of your own has died but these are
our
own and it is onfair and Egypt will
stand with Palestine the United Nations
standing C all these International
institutions are standing for Israel
who's there for the Palestinians and
don't call it War the jargon is even
more infuriating s War they're not equal
footing I've been criticized of the last
two weeks for asking Palestinian
supporters if they condemn the Hamas
Terror attacks but I do it precisely
because of the deadlock in this debate
if Israel supporters can't accept the
Palestinians need and deserve better and
Palestine supporters can't accept that
those attacks were evil then we're stuck
we're stuck in an intractable and deadly
conflict that will continue to rage and
Sim
for many years to come costing countless
more innocent lives Queen Rony of Jordan
gave a powerful interview today in which
he called out the double standard as she
sees it over Israeli and Gaz and death
and she ended by saying this there can
never be a resolution except around the
negotiating table you know and and and
and the and there's only one path to
this and that is a a free Sovereign and
independent Palestinian State living
side by side in peace and security with
the state of
Israel well on that point I think she's
right and so does President Biden who
came out and said the same thing today
they have to be concessions and
compromis on both sides to get there
that's basically where I am on all this
I'm not a Middle East expert I don't
have any personal skin in the game I
lament the loss of every innocent life
on both sides I think we have to unite
around our basic human compassion before
we can move forward well I'm joined now
from Cairo by Rak maain who's power
message has gone viral online rakman
thank you very much indeed for joining
me we've got a a slight delay uh in the
connection between us so I'm going to
ask you uh questions and give you time
to answer them uh rather than try and
talk over you because that isn't going
to work uh given the delay so let me
just ask you first of all you were on
CNN I know Clarissa Ward the
correspondent that you were uh very
passionate towards in in my opinion
having worked to CNN she is one of the
best foreign correspondents in the world
and I felt uh absolutely has tried to
straddle uh this very tricky line of
reporting fairly and accurately on what
is a a horrendous conflict um when you
look back at yourself in that exchange
with Clarissa how do you feel about the
way that you addressed her do you have
any regret or do you feel you could have
expressed yourself differently or do you
feel it accurately represented how you
were
feeling I'm not going to wait Wast my
time talking about the report with
Clarissa uh because this takes away from
the point You' mentioned before there
was a deadlock in the debate there's no
deadlock in the debate there is Terror
in the debate you are unable to debate
with Israel because what's happened so
far is we're witnessing the sick
relationship between the United States
and Israel where basically uh the United
States has given uh a permission for
Israel to uh have genocide on ground and
what's happened is we're seeing uh no
one can say no to Israel the United
Nations isn't able to say no to Israel
without repercussions uh media in media
figures aren't able to say no to Israel
without uh without repercussions so what
ends up happening is that you're
basically raising a spoiled brat you're
unable to say no to that has now grown
up to be a sociopath and let me
reiterate that the relationship between
the United States and Israel is putting
the world in ja ardy so what we're
witnessing now is a a a serious issue
where both parties need to reassess
their relationship I understand that
Biden because he's pitted his own people
against each other and wasted billions
of dollars uh giving them to Israel
instead of looking at his own homeless
his own medical uh care issue his own
student loans issue so a lot of American
people are also extremely angry and
they're also looking at unfair coverage
the reason this video has gone so viral
one it's alarming that it's gone so
viral because what should be going viral
is the footage that we are witnessing
out of Palestine out of the occupied
territories of children being massacred
it's not a war a war assumes that both
parties are on equal
footing okay I hear you uh what I would
say in response to that uh is that on o
October the 7th Hamas who are the ruling
Authority in Gaza committed an act of
such heinous terrorism killing 1500
people including 260 people at the music
FAL let me finish let me finish let me
ask the militia raak let let me just ask
you the question I'm really I'm I'm no
no you have to let me ask a question
I've been very polite to you and
respectful I've let you have your say
I'm going to say something now to you
and you can respond mind there's a delay
so this isn't exactly the easiest debate
to have well that's why I said at the
start why don't we let me ask questions
you answer them and that's the way this
can proceed in a respectful manner I
would simply say to you that I've had a
number of pro Palestinian voices on this
program in the last two weeks um and a
number of pro-israel voices many of the
pro Palestinian people I've had on have
been very quick to condemn what Hamas
did on October the 7th some have
not what's your position before we get
to what you just said to me about what
Israel has done and what America is
doing and so on what is your view as
someone in Egypt about what happened
right on your border there in Gaza uh by
Hamas against
Israel it's a very fair question but the
thing is maybe I have a priv
being so close to the Border having many
Palestinian friends uh knowing more
history uh that I understand that once
you oppress a people and again I'm not
justifying what happened the killing of
civilians on both parts ought to be
condemned but the danger in you starting
an interview asking me to condemn Hames
then pours into Israel's blind def
defense of its own state which ends up
killing over 5,000 Palestinians over 700
dead and going back to the report that
you were discussing at the beginning
with the CNN reporter the issue with
that is everything is always taken out
of context and this is the issue we have
with Western media had the journalist uh
been there on ground with the volunteers
that night as for example I was she
would have listened to the bombardment
of Israel
uh bombs that start from 2:30 a.m. and
do not stop she would have also witness
the fact that we would get an okay from
Israel's side I'm not done from Israel's
side that the supplies would go in and
then it's like they toy with your morale
so that you hope from both sides is
stopped the narrative has got to change
the idea I I for example I don't have
the PR of Israel I don't have the money
to uh to to hire the Justin beavers of
the world and and and have them say pray
for Israel and whatnot but what I do
have is the truth and the reason this
video has gone so viral is because
people felt it people felt that let me
ask a question
rakma so my question is this when Hamas
did what they did on October the 7th
they will have known absolutely known
that Israel's response would have been
this and it would have involved the
deaths of many thousands of innocent
people in Gaza as a consequence of going
after Hamas they will have known that so
my question for you again a difficult
question I appreciate this given that
you're right there in the middle of all
this but the difficult question is how
do regular Palestinian people feel that
their ruling Authority commit an act of
Terror so heinous and they must have
known how Israel would respond
and they must have known that many
thousands of innocent Palestinians would
die as a consequence of that terror
attack how do they feel about that are
they comfortable with Hamas continuing
to be the ruling Authority in Gaza or is
it actually an act of such appalling
atrocity well that hamash should no
longer be there and if if the answer is
the Palestinian people don't want them
to be there anymore then how do you get
rid of
them unfort fortunately the Palestinian
people don't have the luxury of the time
to think of Hames the the the voice
notes we're receiving from our
Palestinians Palestinian brothers and
sisters from under the rubble from uh
mothers who've lost their childrens from
home families that have been eradicated
the the sentiment we're getting from the
Palestinian people is do they see us if
the United Nations that's whole premise
was to avoid avoid this kind of genocide
was created to avoid this kind of
humanitarian crisis cannot stand up to
one spoiled brat of a fascist
organization then where are we in this
world and what's sad is that it's a top-
down movement you have the United
Nations unable to speak to Israel you
also have the the the people at work who
cannot hold the Palestinian flag who get
fired on the spot I've had people who
work in New York text me and tell me
that they've been fired on the spot you
know what else I've had that I
unfortunately I cannot show screenshot
and last thing screenshots of emails
from from prominent news channels where
anchors where um younger people are are
emailing producers begging are emailing
one another begging why aren't we
showing the other side why aren't you
showing the other side because what
what's happened is that I have to be
Israel has given you a brand book where
you can so that you can be prim and
proper in front of your I have to be a
respond clear about their intent they've
been very clear since the hag you have
to let me respond now okay I'm listening
to you respectfully I am not the media
I've given more of a platform to Pro
Palestinian people including yourself
than any other show in the world so I
resent the suggestion that I'm just like
everybody else which Del given I have
deliberately given large chunks of my
show each night to voices like yours to
tell the side of the Palestinians but
again I come back to this you talk about
genocide by Israel against Palestinian
people what do you call the Hamas stated
intent they've made no secret of it it's
their stated intent to wipe Israel off
the face of the Earth to kill all Jews
and that's exactly what we saw them try
to do on October the 7th what do you
call that if it's not
genocide but you've seen that from the
other side you know it's interesting
because this point brings one to be
called and dubbed anti-semitic you know
I believe that Israel is the most
anti-Semitic entity ever we used to live
with our Jewish brothers and sisters
here in the Middle East and in Palestine
and the creation of Israel on a racist
premise differentiated because you had
you didn't have uh uh Jewish Arabs or
whatnot you just had Arabs they were
Christian they were the people of
pal they were Muslim um they were
Jewish I don't need to because the
problem is the why are we having a
debate is it not to solve or is this for
another Sensational interview is this a
sensational interview about sens to
solve I you accused Israel of genocide
ceas because the world is in
danger I have accused Israel of genocide
I am accusing Israel ofci saying to a
genocide simp a genocide rakma I hear
you and you're perfectly entitled to
that view although Israel would contest
that characterization of what they have
been doing but many would agree with you
but I simply say what is Hamas waging
against Israel I would love if they
would contest with evidence rather than
Terror but do you not agree with me that
what Hamas is doing is clearly do you
not agree with me that clearly what
Hamas is waging against Israel is also
genocide by your
criteria I am I am you know what's again
again this is a dangerous uh debate
because what you're trying to put me in
is once I condemn asking a question this
once I condemn these people what that
then means what is why is this dangerous
for me because what that then means is
that you can then answer me and tell me
that Israel has the unequivocal right to
defend itself which what mean which what
that means is that they eradicate a
people who end up
being so why to stop to this now they're
not on equal footing let me clarify
Israel like every country in the world
has an absolute right to defend itself
right Israel has a right to defend
itself the question now is what is and
children let me let me finish my
point let me finish my point how many
Palestinians have died if you're not
going to let me finish my point you're
not going to hear what I have to say
Israel has a right to defend itself but
the longer this war goes on the more
that people are saying to Israel what is
proportionate how can killing many
thousands of Palestinians innocent women
and children how can that be right if if
what happened October the seventh is
wrong how can this be right and it's a
very fair point to make but my point
about all of this is you want peace I
want peace the president of the United
States and queen Ru and others saying
we've got to get to a two-state solution
to do that you've got to have leadership
which can be trusted by the other side
there is no way that Israel will ever
trust any leadership involving Hamas and
I would say the same by the way about uh
the Palestinian view of Benjamin
Netanyahu I don't think they trust him
either that you need new leadership on
both sides and and that's where the
conundrum is going to be how do you get
to that place where it's no longer Hamas
controlling pal Palestinians and no
longer Benjamin Netanyahu in charge of
the Israeli
side excellent question you apply
international law you apply
international law you allow the United
Nations to do its job when when when the
Hames situation happened for example it
was supposed to be the Red Cross to go
and negotiate Israel is is stopping all
of that on top of that it's also
terrorizing the media on top of that
it's also terrorizing individuals on top
of that it has money being poured in
from the United Nation from the United
States on top of that it has the backing
of the European Union on top of that it
has the backing of Britain that started
this whole Force so what ends up
happening is who's speaking for the
Palestinian people so for a solution to
happen you need to empower the United
Nations so that Israel is not making a
mockery of the United Nations how am I
needing to reiterate this more and more
I am giving you a solution rakma you're
giving me your you're still telling me
Hames RMA you always be Hames if you
occupy a people let me just finish this
point let me just finish this point if
you occupy a people if you occupy a
people if uh women in labor are having
to give birth at checkpoints if you're
having uh people imprisoned if you're
having this merciless bombardment of
Palestinians you are going to breed
Hames it starts with the stronger
party rakma I've given you uh a long
amount of time and this is why the
jargon is dangerous okay I hear you and
I respect your right to your opinion and
I've given you the platform to air them
and I appreciate you coming on the
program you
then that's not my job my job is to try
and interview people at the center of
this you may not like that but it is but
I appreciate you coming on the program
interviews sure it wasn't Sensational it
wasn't but thank you very much well
coming up as Israel warns at the ground
invasion is coming I'll talk to the
Palestinian legislative council member
Mustafa Bugatti bug bouti I'm sorry
that's uncensored next live from New
York
City
[Music]
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored in
New York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just starred
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know what I love about
tour today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
R I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going to
take the side of boozed up Brits against
these pomp you mean you're not going to
support mayor Jose l
stop pying to the nimes to the naysayers
and The National Society for the
preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like there
highly paid concerns don't really know
what they're
doing first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you we're just asking patients to be
patient with
us the one thing label would be
terrified of if Boris Johnson zoomed
back into full Focus Boris Johnson isn't
what he was most of them seem to have
given up welcome to the talk it's really
great to be back my Little Darlings kids
think all they have to do is stay at
home be silly take pictures of
everything just shut down Tik Tock then
yeah problem problem solved
fit as a butcher's dog there you go he's
fit as a butcher's dog him all right but
but he's now middle class three us here
Tess the knock on effect is far larger
than just CO2 I nearly have empathy when
I'm speaking to them I know now you're
probably going to boot me off show
this colly I'm not I'm not a Swifty
critics I'd say me included got former
PMS all over the joint saying things the
last few days we have indeed yeah great
first show you having fun oh a ton of
fun King peer and King Cube I think it's
only room for one King you know I'm
saying just cuz they're skin folk don't
mean they're kin folk when I say I am
God you think I'm joking or not you tell
me I'm not joking I'd rather do it on
camera no no no no if it's on camera
we're not doing an interview why we'll
explain why how do you feel about that
influence that you had you better be
careful we're coming for your children
there buddy about Maring Nation yes I'm
going to go you're going to result yes
cuz I cannot continue my work it was a
fabulous dinner until you two uh mooned
us
thank God for talk TV is not only the
home of common sense it's the only place
where you get the
[Music]
truth welcome back to uncensored live
from New York City last time I spoke to
my next guest it was just two days after
the horrific mass killings on October
the 7th Millions saw that interview many
praised his pragmatism about the crisis
ahead with guards are facing catastrophy
and on the brink of an Israeli Grand
Invasion about been back to assess what
happens next and I'm joined from rala by
the Palestinian national initiative
leader Mustafa bouti Mr baruti thank you
very much indeed for rejoining me A lot
has happened obviously since we last
spoke what is your assessment of where
we are in this
war we are in a very terrible position
and situation because the Israeli
attacks on Gaza
continue uh I mean I mean at this moment
they're not losing Israelis all the
victims are Palestinians what we see
here is after the process of
dehumanization of Palestinians they are
in the act of annihilation of
Palestinian people uh massacres after
massacres after massacres up till now
almost 7,000 people have been killed in
Gaza uh mostly
civilians and uh and in add and out of
that about
2,700 children have been killed these
are not just numbers uh moments ago one
of our colleagues and your colleague the
main journalist the main journalist in
Gaza the correspondent of Al jazer lost
his wife and his daughter and his son
lost his family in an air strike in an
area which was supposed to be a safe
place according to Israeli instructions
they forced people to come from the
north to the South and his family was
bombarded and killed and nobody can say
that they were human shields for Hamas
this big lie that is that keeps
repeating today we were in a
demonstration in in solidarity with Gaza
and one of the other journalist his name
is Muhammad Farah suddenly collapsed
because he got the message from Gaza
that his sister and all her family were
killed just like that he did not have
the chance to meet his sister for 24
years you know why because Israel would
not allow his sister to come from Gaza
to the West Bank and would not allow him
to go from here to Gaza for 24 years he
did not see his sister and now she is
killed with her children with her
husband this is unacceptable
Palestinians are human beings and these
are not just numbers no I I completely
agree with you and every least every
innocent life is being lost is a
catastrophe in this war war is a
catastrophe let's be completely straight
about this uh I know that you're not
associated with Hamas Hamas when they
launched this appalling terror attack on
October the 7th they would have known
how Israel would respond how can it be
right how can it be good for the
Palestinian people that they continue to
have Hass ruling them in Gaza when
they've committed a terror atrocity
which they knew before they enacted it
would sparkk this kind of response from
Israel not to defend what Israel's doing
but they knew this is how they would
respond they knew thousands of
Palestinians would be killed how can
that be what is good for the Palestinian
people there are two answers to your
question the first answer is that what
what what the General Secretary of the
United Nations said yesterday in the
security Council which is that history
did not start on the 7th of October he
said what happened did not happen in a
vacuum he condemned the attacks on
Israelis of course but he said that this
did not happen in a vacuum it was a
result of the fact that we have been
under Israeli military occupation for 56
years that which a result of the fact
that 70% of the population of Gaza like
most Palestinians have been evicted from
their land by Israel back in 1948 in an
act of ethnic cleansing where 520
Palestinian communities were erased to
the ground and where 52 huge massacres
took place he he reminded the world that
there is a context context of what's
happening and he reminded the world of
the suffering of the Palestinian people
what did get Mr hun by Israel no no no
no let me finish I I want
to the rest of the answer important
Point Mr
got wi hunting by Israel he is witch
hunted Now by Israel yeah but I
understand why I understand why Israel's
been so angered by what he said because
what he was trying to do was offer some
kind of justification to something to
something which is completely
unjustified you cannot in any context
say that this terror attack series of
terror attack he didn't say that October
7th was anything other than pure evil
terrorism and the moment you trying to
equivocate the you try and bring in
historical stuff to try and explain why
this may have happened there is no
justification surely for what
happened I I hope that you will make
your questions a bit shorter because you
have to give me some time to respond
first no I don't think he did anything
wrong and now they're witch hunting him
they say he should resign you know what
this you you as a journalist would agree
with me that any person who is not part
of this situation should be should try
to be balanced right should not take a
one side and not the other yes and uh
but but but what what the what what the
Israeli foreign minister Cohen said
yesterday that from now
on nobody should be allowed to be
balanced it's either you are with us or
you are our enemy they're witch hunting
not only goish you know even the Israeli
woman who was a prisoner in Gaza who was
released they accused her of being a
liar just because this old lady who 85
years old dared to say that she was
treated properly that they took care of
her that they didn't beat her didn't
didn't torture her and then Israelis
themselves themselves called her a Liah
this is unacceptable and by all means
what is happening are collective
punishment against Palestinian people
people acts of ethnic cleansing and
genocide by which law by which law the
world accepts that Palestinians are
deprived of fuel in Gaza when children
are dying in incubators because they
cannot get
electricity by which law in this world
120 Palestinians who are in emergency in
urgent need for kidney dialysis will die
because they cannot get dialysis
including 20 children but I didn't
respond I didn't finish the response to
your question about Hamas my answer to
you is we should have free Democratic
elections and we should have the chance
to elect our leadership freely and
democratically had we had had we have
elections in 2021 we would not be in
this situation because all the polls
showed that neither Hamas nor fat will
get absolute majority
we would have had a pluralistic
democratic system who was against our
elections Israel who was against our
elections the United States of America
the great Democratic
country which is the the president of
which unfortunately is hurting his own
credibility Now by by repeating
netanyahu's lies one time after the
other okay why don't they allow us to
have Democratic free
elections a good question is the
response to Mr bti I think the I think
the the concept of free election would
be total anatha to Hamas uh but I
appreciate you have that opinion and I
appreciate you coming on the program
again thank you very
much but up next world famous Israeli
historian yval Noah Harari with a
fascinating interview on what history
can teach us about the crisis in Israel
that's un sensive
[Music]
next
[Applause]
[Music]
this is talk
TV welcome back to S my next guest is an
Israeli academic who's bestselling books
like sapiens explore the Human Condition
from a dawn of History to today so take
on the current conflict is worth hearing
he says as well as winning the military
war Israel needs to win the war of his
own Humanity by treating Palestinians
with dignity and provided them with a
future I sat down with newval no Harari
to find out more well I'm joined Now by
yal no Harari yal thank you very much
indeed for joining me I wanted to start
on a personal note I understand that you
had family members uh at the Kutz when
these Horrors were unfurling on October
the 7th uh how are they and tell me
about what they experienced well my my
aunt and uncle live in kibutz ber which
is one of the communities that was
attacked and occupied by the Kamas
terrorists uh my aunt and uncle who are
he's 100 years old and my aunt is 90
years old they hid in their house as
terrorists went systematically from
house to house in their kibuts and
tortured and executed and murdered
people their neighbors and friends in
the most horrific ways uh they somehow
survived and they and tens of thousands
of other Israelis from the border region
are now refugees inside in in Israel I
mean a horrific experience as so many
experienced on that day I've been
debating on this show ever since about
what constitutes a proportional response
by Israel I'm sure that you've wrestled
with that too what have you concluded
what is the correct response here for
Israel to retaliate or exact revenge or
just to defend themselves however you
want to categorize it what is the best
way for Israel to do this we need to
look to the Future and in the present
circumstances this means that on the one
hand Israel must defend its uh citizens
and must disarm Hamas and end the Hamas
control of the Gaza Strip not just so
that my family and tens of thousands of
other Israelis could go back to living
next to the Gaza Strip but also Hamas is
intentionally destroying any chance for
future peace you know the reason this
attack was launched now the reason for
the timing of the attack was that Israel
was very close to signing a historical
peace treaty with Saudi Arabia uh which
was supposed not just to normalize
relations between Israel and the Arab
world but also to restart the Israeli
Palestinian peace process and to include
concessions that will alleviate the
suffering of millions of Palestinians in
the occupied territories and the aim of
Hamas was to foil this peace treaty even
those interested in peace must be in
favor of disarming Hamas at the same
time Israel should remain committed to
international law and to the Future
chances for peace there will not
be peace just by disarming Kamas we also
need to give a future to the
Palestinians in the god strip and in the
West Bank so that they can live
dignified lives in their Homeland but
how do you dismantle or eradicate Hamas
given they're a terror group that live
amongst the civilian population we know
this if and if you need the population
to come with you on this process of
removing Hamas surely what is going on
at the moment is having the opposite
effect if thousands and thousands of
Palestinian civilians who had nothing to
do with it are being Slaughter
um on a daily basis it seems and if that
escalates through a ground Invasion then
surely it will have the opposite effect
won't it I mean you may well end up
dismantling a lot of Hamas terrorists
but if you also kill tens maybe hundreds
of thousands of civilians you are surely
going to alienate those people from
wanting any form of deal with anybody
after this absolutely and this is why
Israel should be very careful about the
way it operates uh Israel is not a
terrorist organization like Hamas it is
not aiming to kill as many civilians as
possible uh it is very difficult of
course to fight a terrorist organization
which is hiding inside a civilian
population ideally uh there should be a
way for civilians to move out of the
combat zones uh Egypt that shares a
border with the Gaza Strip uh should be
willing to accept Palestinian civilians
for the duration of of the war in order
to protect them I would say that even
Israel should explore the possibility of
receiving at least women and children
from the Gaza Strip into Israeli
territory you know maybe allow the Red
Cross or some other international
organization to build temporary safe
havens for gazan civilians on Israeli
soil for the duration of the conflict if
Israel wins the war against Hamas
without providing for an alternative
future for the Palestinian civilian
population we will only get something
even worse than Kamas a few years down
the line you're a historian as you said
earlier this has been going on now for
over 70 years this conflict yeah it
flares up um every few years it seems
with some new form of of hideous Warfare
uh when you chart back to the the very
start of all this which many people are
trying to do to try to explain how we've
reached this place was the big mistake
in the first place the displacement of
several hundred thousand Palestinians
people for instance talk a lot these
days and and for many years and for good
reasons about the suffering of hundreds
of thousands of Palestinians who lost
their homes in 1948 few people know that
as a result of the 1948 War also
hundreds of thousands of Jews lost their
homes in retaliation for the War uh
Jewish communities all over the Middle
East in Arab countries in Egypt in Iraq
in Yemen in Syria who lived there for
hundreds sometimes thousands of years
and had nothing to do with the war they
were driven out hundreds of thousands of
Jews the largest group of people now
living in Israel are Jew
that were expelled as refugees as a
result of the 1948 War now does this
justify what happened to the
Palestinians no does this justify the
Israeli occupation and the mistreatment
of Palestinians there absolutely not
then we shouldn't use historical
injuries to justify more injuries if you
have to choose between Justice and peace
choose peace every peace treaty in the
history of the world was based on
compromise no we need some level of
justice of course but there is never a
possibility of absolute Justice if you
pursue absolute Justice you will only
perpetuate War indefinitely most people
believe there can be no peace deal with
Hamas given the appalling Terror attacks
of October the 7th but many people also
feel including many Israelis I've talked
to believe there can't be any peace
steel as long as BB net Yahoo remains in
charge of Israel uh do you share that
view do you think that uh that on well
for many reasons one his attack earlier
in the year on the Judiciary on the
Integrity of the Supreme Court the
social unrest like cause the division in
Israel perhaps even distracted his
defense and intelligence uh people away
from uh from what they should have been
doing which may have contributed to the
way Hamas was able to execute this
attack uh for all these reasons do you
think it would be prudent for Israel to
find new leadership absolutely I mean
Netanyahu has been ruling Israel for
most of the last 14 years he has based
his political career on dividing the
nation against itself he has weakened
any state institution including the
security forces that might challenge or
limit his authority as he recently tried
to do to the courts and especially to
the Supreme Court and this is is the
deep cause of the
dysfunction of many governmental systems
not only on the day of the attack but in
in ever since then if Natan really cared
about the state of Israel he should have
just taken responsibility for the
disaster and
resigned and allowed the Israeli people
to come together at this very difficult
time alternatively if he thinks he's the
only one that can manage
this crisis then he should have said
okay I'm calling an election in six
months and then I will resign and and
and and take responsibility for for what
has
happened well you can watch a lot more
from my full fascinating interview uh
with that fascinating character on the
peers Morgan uncensored YouTube page
very soon a very smart guy with a very
smart take on all this next up I'm
joined by the most formidable judge in
America Janine Piro making a uncensored
debut next live from New York
[Music]
City we're here good morning everybody
hope you're well thanks for joining us
you're watching the independent republic
of Mike gra right here on talk TV
welcome to Friday night with Nadine here
on prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening up Pi's Morgan uncensored in New
York City very impressive well
played I'm three days into the job what
have I done wrong and your face just
starred out at me me and you conquer
time who wins you do you know what I
love about SCH today we do it all sunak
sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
the she I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going
to take the side of booze du
against these pump you mean you're not
going to support mayor Jose L
not stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's highly paid Consultants
don't really know what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you and we're
just asking patients to be patient with
us the one thing labor would be
terrified of if Boris Johnson zoomed
back into full Focus Boris Johnson uh
isn't what he was most of them seem to
have given up welcome to the talk it's
really great to be back my Little
Darlings kids think all they have to do
is stay at home be silly take pictures
of every everything just shut down Tik
Tock then
yeah problem
solved fit as a butcher's dog there you
go he's fit as a butchest dog all right
but but he's now middle class here test
the knock on effect is far larger than
just CO2 I nearly have empathy when I'm
speaking to them I know know you're
probably going to boot me after show
thisly I'm not I'm not a Swifty critics
i' say me included got former PMS all
over the joint saying things the last
few days we have indeed yeah great first
show you having fun oh a ton of fun King
PE and King Cube I think there's only
room for one king man you know what I'm
saying just cuz they're skin folk don't
mean they're kin folk when I say I am
God you think I'm joking or not you tell
me I'm not joking I'd rather do it on
camera no no no no if it's on camera
we're not doing an interview why we'll
explain why how do you feel about that
influence that you had you better be
careful we're coming for your children
there buddy about Maring Nation yes I'm
going to do you're going to Res yes cuz
cannot continue my work it was a
fabulous dinner until you two uh mooned
us thank God for talk TV is not only the
home common sense it's the only place
where you get the
[Music]
truth at Midtown Manhattan there the
home of news corporation and fox where I
am currently tonight welcome to
uncensored from New York City I'm joined
by judge Janine Pirro the co-host of Fox
news's channel the five uh Fox news
channels the five the number one show
cable I'm doing it with you this week
that's right judge Janine and it's great
it's a great show to be on and that's
why I'm so happy to have you on my show
well I'm delighted to be here thank you
give me your overview of where we are
with this
war um I think that we're seeing evil
play out I think that many people people
never expected that it would be as bad
as it was when October 7th came about it
was like you know this is a revisiting
of the Holocaust I feel like we're in a
pre-World War II moment that the only
thing missing is Crystal knock that uh
the lines have been set uh the Jews
again are the people that are being
attacked the people that that others
want to exterminate and I have to tell
you peers I don't understand it I don't
understand why from the beginning of
time have they wanted to erase Jews but
you know what that's this is where we
are and we've got the United States that
has been funding Iran at least during
the Obama Administration with the love
letters we can do this deal and you know
let's do it nuclear deal meanwhile
they're hiding that the fact that
they're they're they're developing the
plutonium at forto uh and then Trump
comes in and says no way takes the money
away cuts the deal Biden's back giving
them millions of dollars and then
allowing them to sell oil on the
international market what does that have
to do with this the United States
government for the first week or so
refused to say that Iran was involved
everybody else understood that Iran was
involved Hamas gets its money from Iran
Hezbollah gets its money from Iran and
so now we know what the axis of Evil is
and we've got Israel that unfortunately
was in a position where they did not
live up to their reputation in terms of
intelligence and nor did the United
States and so400 people were murdered
barbarically medieval style horrific I
mean you burn babies and girls let me
ask you a difficult question everyone
with a brain understands Israel is
entitled to defend itself and has a duty
actually a responsibility to defend its
people from any further attacks like
this from Hamas who are dedicated to
eradicating Israel and and Jewish people
right but when you go in to Gaza and you
attack Hamas in the way that Israel's
been doing with these air strikes before
there's even a ground Invasion thousands
of civilians are going to get killed
because Hamas live amongst the civilian
population is there a limit in your eyes
to the scale of Israel's response here
no Israel is a nation that is surrounded
by people who want to kill them you know
you've heard the the statement you know
from The River To The Sea you know just
get rid of Israel the truth is that
Israel faces this existential threat and
if they don't take care of that threat
now they will never be safe the the
Jewish people the Israeli people will
die so you say to yourself but you know
it's not fair it's not proportional what
is proportional I ask you this in World
War II 350,000 to 500,000 Germans were
killed they were civilians they didn't
deserve to die This Is War peers this is
what it calls for those kind of actions
and there's no doubt that they spent two
years planning this this was very
sophisticated this was done in a way
where the intelligence agencies in the
United States and Israel didn't have any
clue they were using landlines how are
we going to get it I mean I was a DA you
got to tap the landline you're not going
in a tunnel to do that is it lawful what
Israel is currently doing and about to
do with the ground Invasion absolutely
they have to do it they don't have a
choice this isn't a dance this isn't
like when he moves his left step I I
move my my right foot that's not how it
works you've got to destroy the enemy
the people who are dying the
Palestinians who are dying and will die
are dying because of Hamas Hamas will
not let them out Egypt will not
assimilate them uh Jordan says I've got
a red line I'm not taking them that
Queen ra can talk about it all she wants
maybe she she ought to talk to King King
Abdullah and say you know what honey I'm
out there promoting the Palestinians why
don't you bring some of them into Jordan
you know they're all Hypocrites this is
a war you put on your big boy pants or
your big girl pants and you understand
there's a problem now the hospitals in
Palestine I'll give you an example there
they say that they cannot they're not
operating because they don't have fuel
you know who has fuel Hamas has fuel uh
uh Iran has fuel and when they talked
about that that that uh uh hostage who
was released she talked about the
doctors how clean it was how they had
food how even the toilets were clean
underground tunnel all underground there
are 400 miles of underground tunnels
we're talking about cities underground
what do you make of the in my view
unbelievably grotesque response of
students but especially in the United
States who've been launching endless Pro
Hamas demonstrations putting stuff onto
buildings beaming support for what do
you make of that well I think it's been
coming for a long time I think that the
educational system in the United States
is on a decline I mean we just talked on
the five about the fact that in Oregon
they don't care if you pass they're just
going to let you leave school and say
you graduated look for the longest time
we've dealt with young people in college
you know my feelings are hurt I need a
corner to cry in um you need to
understand how I feel you know these the
microaggressions you know how I feel how
you make me feel how you should feel
it's all about feelings then all of a
sudden when they're confronted with
grotesque uh inhuman crimes they're like
I support the other no feelings for that
for the people that suffer at all I mean
at all and the reason the reason peers
that I mentioned the tunnels is that
Palestinians are nothing more than pawns
to Hamas Hamas is living well the
Palestinians are the Pawns in this War I
think the Palestinian people need to
realize how bad Hamas have been Hamas
Palestinians look Israel said 2005 we'll
give you a Hass judge I've got to leave
it there we run out of time the good
news is you and I going to go and work
on the five in an hour's time great to
have you please come back again I love
that whatever is you're up to tonight
keep it un sensed good
[Music]
night
[Applause]
[Music]